♪♪
IN THIS BALLOON IS A FART.
Rachel: WE'LL BE FIRING UP
THIS HIGH-POWERED LASER
DOWNRANGE TOWARDS OUR BALLOON.
THAT WAY, WE CAN SAFELY ASSESS
IF ADAM'S FARTS
CAN BE IGNITED BY A LASER,
AND THIS IS CLOSER THAN I EVER
WANT MY FACE TO ADAM'S FARTS.
WE ARE SHOOTING FARTS
WITH LASERS FOR SCIENCE.
LET THAT SINK INTO
YOUR HEADS.
HOW COOL IS THAT?
-IT'S KIND OF WEIRD, TOO.
-HOW DID YOU...
Narrator:
YEP, WEIRD SCIENCE, ALL RIGHT.
THIS PUPPY'S FOR REAL.
SHOOTING FARTS WITH LASERS
IN 3...
2...1.
[ LOUD POP ]
AAH!
OH, MY GOD!
THAT WAS JUST
A BALLOON POPPING.
I DON'T THINK I SAW
ANY FIRE WHATSOEVER.
WHY DIDN'T IT WORK?
WE KNOW FARTS ARE FLAMMABLE.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I SEE TWO POSSIBLE EXPLANATIONS.
ONE IS THAT THE CONCENTRATION
OF METHANE IN MY FART MIXTURE
MIGHT NOT BE ENOUGH
TO SEE A FLAME,
OR IT COULD BE THAT THE LASER
DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH POWER
TO IGNITE THE GAS.
IT'S JUST POPPING
THE BALLOON.
Narrator:
THE MOST COMBUSTIBLE COMPONENT
OF ADAM'S SYN-FLATUS
IS THE METHANE,
BUT IT'S ONLY 7%
OF THE TOTAL VOLUME.
SO CAN THE LASER
IGNITE A BALLOON
FILLED WITH PURE METHANE?
Jesse: ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS METHANE
LASER EXPLOSION...
-MAYBE.
-HOPEFULLY!
...IN 3...2...1.
[ LOUD POP ]
AAH!
-WOW!
-UH, LETDOWN.
Jesse: SO WHERE'S
OUR BIG EXPLOSION?
Narrator: ONCE AGAIN,
THE LASER POPS THE BALLOON,
BUT THERE'S NO FIREBALL.
Rachel: THE LASER'S POWERFUL
ENOUGH TO POP THE BALLOON,
BUT NOT IGNITE THE GAS.
SEE HERE?
THE BLACK MATTER IS OUR GAS
ESCAPING INTO THE ATMOSPHERE...
NOT ON FIRE.
WHAT ABOUT JUST TRYING
A LIGHTER
ON A BALLOON
FULL OF THE FART MIXTURE
VERSUS A BALLOON
FULL OF METHANE,
JUST TO GET
A CROSS-COMPARISON?
Narrator: ADAM SUITS UP TO CHECK
THAT THE GAS' FLAMMABILITY
IS NOT WHAT'S GONNA
BUST THIS MYTH.
3, 2, 1.
[ EXPLOSION ]
-WHOA!
-THERE WE GO!
THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
Narrator:
THE METHANE FIREBALL CONFIRMS
IT WAS THE LASER FAILING
TO IGNITE THE GAS.
OKAY.
BRING ON ONE OF MY FARTS!
[ Laughing ] I WANT TO SET
SOME STUFF ON FIRE NOW!
AND JUST TO BE SURE THAT
ADAM'S OWN OUTPUT BURNS, TOO...
-FART IS POSITIONED.
-OKAY.
MY FART IS SETTLED
INTO THE FART-HOLDER.
MY HAND...
IS ON THE LIGHTER.
LET'S MAKE SOME SCIENCE.
[ Laughing ]
ADAM'S FLATUS IN 3...
[ LAUGHS ]
...2, 1.
[ POP ]
-WHOA!
-[ LAUGHS ]
THAT WAS GOOD!
I FELT THE HEAT!
THAT WAS A FART!
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator:
YEP, THE SYN-FLATUS CAUSES
A NOT-SO-SILENT-BUT-DEADLY
BACKDRAFT.
♪♪